la légion donnait un petit badge rouge
et vert décerné à des auteurs des
artistes des politiques des sportifs
mais au juste la légion d'honneur c'est
quoi une bonne caisse la légion
d'honneur c'est une invention de
napoléon bonaparte en 1802 elle sert à
distinguer une personne à titre civil ou
militaire
mais attention la légion d'honneur ne se
réclame pas ah non thomas h le
recrutement des futurs chevaliers de la
légion d'honneur commence à l'échelle
locale par des propositions d'élus
locaux ou de citoyens qui adressent
leurs suggestions au ministre mais en
encore les ministres envoient leur
sélection à la grande chancellerie de la
légion 17 membres
un seul critère c'est le mérite est
mineure le mérites éminents c'est à dire
une action remarquable reconnu comme
modèle pour la société d'intérêt pour la
communauté et en général après au moins
20 ans d'activité mais encore la grande
chancellerie soumet une liste au
président de la république c'est lui qui
a le dernier mot
après consultation du conseil des
ministres mais encore
et c'est parti pour la grosse fête à
l'elysée enfin voilà quoi
en échange les chevaliers de la légion
d'honneur reçoivent une belle médaille
parmi les décorés un paquet de
célébrités
la légion est aussi décernés à des
anonymes
jeanne cote ouvrière à la redoute à
roubaix bien d'être après 68 ans de
service dans la même maison décorée de
la légion d'honneur
c'est quand même une décoration qu'on a
donné à maurice papon bachar el assad ou
harvey wine style enfin la légion leur a
été retiré d'autres en revanche ont
toujours leur légion d'honneur franco
mussolini ceausescu
et comme ils sont morts la chancellerie
n'enlève pas leurs titres car ils ne
peuvent pas défendre leur cause un
ponçage qui se passe sur la durée à la
légion ça peut se perdre mais ça peut
aussi se refusait par humilité comme
bernard pivot andrew de me retrouver
avec mon petit ruban rouge devant des
gens que j'admirais dont je sais tu
qu'il ne mettrait beaucoup plus que moi
l'agent de nos biens pour raisons
éthiques comme camus sartre brassens est
l'auteur de bd jacques tardi qui vaut
rien recevoir du pouvoir quel qu'il soit
et de et de l'état la légion synonyme
bonheur de tout un pays
l'insigne rapporte à son digne
détenteurs une belle indemnité de 6
euros de 10 par an business is business
[Musique]